おお!雨降る前日に頭痛くなる系の偏頭痛です
っていうことは明日雨か
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
珍しくちょっと話しますね色々
色々ってつってもまぁ内容は
あの僕そもそもあんまりマンガって読まない派の人間なんですよね
どっちかって言われるとアニメの方が見るんですよね僕
こうやって画面だけ見てたら勝手に進んでいくし声でもわかるし
何か別にしなきゃいけないことがあっても
なんかこうしながらでも見れるのがアニメだと思ってるんで
基本的に僕アニメを見るんですけども
最近ちょっとですねマンガにハマってしまいまして
あのコソコソと色んなマンガを買っております
はじめしゃちょーです
スマホでマンガアプリとかで結構読むんですけど
実際に買うってなるとやっぱそれなりに好きな物しか
買わないなっていうことでちょっと今日は僕が
最近読んでるマンガの紹介をしようと思います
まぁシンプルなんですけども皆さん逆に考えてください
僕そうそうはマンガについて語ることないですから
僕の趣味というかそういうなんかどんなマンガを読んでいるんだろうっていうのを
面白そうだなって思ってなんか読んでくれるとまぁ嬉しいなぐらいの感じで
ちょっと何個か紹介させていただきます
ではいこう
何からいこうか　いやゆーてめっちゃそんなに読んでるわけじゃないっすよ
全然なんか色んなマンガ詳しいわけでもないんで
とりあえず僕が読んでみて面白かったな思うやつを
ちょっと紹介していこうと思います
えーまずはこちらです〈聲の形〉
はい、これはもうなんかすごかったですね
映画化もされててまぁ話の内容としては
あのー、耳が聞こえない女の子のお話なんですよ
映画見てすごい面白そうだなって思って
なんかもっと深く見てみたいなって思ってマンガを買ったわけなんですけど
なかなか考えさせられますね
小学校の時ってこうなんか…ひどいいじめ
悪意はすごいあるわけじゃないんですけども
知らぬ間にやっちゃうひどいいじめみたいなやつがすごい生々しくかかれてて
あの見ててすごい心が痛くなりました
だが主人公はなんか別にそれが悪いことだと思ってないっていうわけでもないんですけど
正しいことだってどこかで思いながらそれをやっちゃってて
まぁ小学校の時に耳が聞こえない女の子にとんでもないようないじめをしてた
主人公が高校になってその子とまた会って
当時のことをどう思ったか
男の子がどう思ってたか、女の子がどう思ってたとか
みたいな感じでちょっとお話がどう動いていくかって所があるんですけど
あのー耳の聞こえないヒロインの女の子の
硝子（しょうこ）ちゃんが
硝子ちゃんまじ可愛んすよ　好き
まぁこれは面白いというか話が気になるというか
重い、重いマンガですね 主人公も結構暗い人間なので
まぁ読んでてすごい夢中になれるマンガでした
まぁ僕はこのマンガを通して何を一番言いたかったいうと
硝子ちゃん好き
続いてはこちら〈食糧人類〉
これはですねアプリのマンガで見つけて
1巻だけ読むとめちゃくちゃ面白いというかなんか展開が気になる
最近のマンガでよくあるんですけどシチュエーションをものすごくして
どうなるんだろうっていう気になりが半端なさすぎて
アプリの枠を超えて実物を買ってしまったっていうやつなんですけども
これはまた面白いというか、設定が面白いですね
まぁこの手のマンガ僕結構好きなんですけど
なんかね地球温暖化がめちゃくちゃ進んだちょっと未来のお話で
主人公が高校生で突然ね帰宅中に拉致されるんですよ
で、拉致された先がなんかよくわかんない場所で
ここでなんか冷凍された人間や、なんかすごい太っちゃった人間の姿
よくわかんないことがたくさんあったんですけども
まぁその理由がこん中に書いてある
ごめんなさい後ろに書いてあるの全部読んじゃいました　悪りぃ
まぁとりあえずねちゃんとその地球温暖化になったのも理由があって
なんでそんな冷凍人間とか太らされた人間がいるかっていうと
もうタイトルの通り食糧人間っていうわけなんですけど
まぁ何か絡んでるなっていうのがわかっていくお話でございます
設定か面白いんすよね
まず人間が冷凍されている時点で
もう、ははｗってそんな爆笑することじゃねぇな
いや大変ですよ人間って冷凍されちゃダメですから
冷凍されたり人間がなんかすごいデブにされたりしてて
インパクトがすごくてちょっとハマっちゃった感じです
これ見せて大丈夫だよね　いいよね
はいこちら
えー〈終末のハーレム〉でございます
5巻まであーもう表紙が
うぅ〜ん///
まぁ一言で言いましょう
これはもうねぇもう設定がねぇもう男の子だったらたまらん
っていうかこれ大丈夫なのかな
設定だけの話をさせていただきますと
主人公が病気にかかってしまいまして、その病気を治すために
これもちょっとまた未来の話なんですけども
あのコールドスリープつって主人公だけ冷凍して何年後かに復活すると
その病気が治ってるよっていう病気にかかっちゃって
5年程ちょっとコールドスリープで主人公だけ時間が止まってたんですよ
主人公が5年後に起きると
なんと世界中の男性が
絶滅していましたあああああ!!!［拍手］
これ何を意味するかと言いますと
主人公が起きた瞬間世界は女の子しかいない状態になってるんですよ
というわけで終末のハーレムというタイトルなんですけど
エッッッッロ
いや、まさにハーレムですどこ見ても女の子ですし
男がいなくなった世界ってまたちょっとやばいじゃないですか
子供も産めないからもう人類が滅亡の道をたどるしかない
けどやっぱそれだとさ、それだとやっぱ
人類が滅亡しちゃうじゃないですか
男性かな、男性は読んでるともう
ふふ///
ってなっちゃうと思います
僕の周りの人も皆んなこれ読んだら「最高」つって帰って行きます
はいラストですこれあのすいませ 僕今日これ読んでて1日終わってしまいました
これねまじで面白いと思うんだよな
〈かぐや様は告らせたい〉
これはかぐやちゃんですね
あ、あの、ぼくはここここここのマンガの、ななななななにをおすすめするかと言いますと
まぁ絵も普通に可愛んですけども
内容がまじであの…
たまたまちょっと本屋さん行く機会があって
なんか書いてあるのがずるいんだよな
天才たちの恋愛頭脳戦っていう
男の子と女の子がいるんですけどもめっちゃ頭いいんすよ
その天才の2人がなんかもう察してるんすよね
2人ともそのお互いがお互いを好きみたいな
あっ好きだなーけど俺もまぁ好きだけどね
あたし、あっわたくしのこと好きなのですねー
まぁ付き合ってやらんこともないですけれどもー
みたいな結構そのプライドの高い2人が
自分から告白なんてするわけねぇーぞと
告白したら負けだぞと
なんとしてでもその上に立ちたいっていう気持ちがあって
その男の子と女の子がどっちが先に告白させるかっていう
そのすごい頭脳戦が繰り広げられている
ははぁｗなんかｗ
まじで面白いっすラブコメっぽく見えるんすけども
すごいなんか深読みしすぎててめちゃくちゃ面白かったです
いやーすいません普通に今日声出して1日中笑ってました
今からちょっと5巻読むんですけども多分
見ててください！マンガで声出して笑ったらほんとに面白いってことだと思うんで、見ます
いやーまじでね2人ともほんとね
2人とも絶対自分から行かないんですよ
これまじでいいマンガですよ！！
割とここ最近で１番ちょっときてる
なんだこのモヤモヤした感情は
やばいどうすんだよ会えないじゃんそれだと！！
おいおいおいおい
やばいやばいぞ
夏休みのくだりがやばい
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｗｗ
なんていってんｗｗｗｗ
待ってごめんなさい
ふざけんなよ!１２３４まで超面白かったのに
なんで4巻（？）からこんな泣かせにくんだよ
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｗｗ
あーﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｗｗ
いやー面白いまじで面白いですこれは
という感じでちょっとマンガにハマっております
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｗｗ
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｗｗ
あ、じゃーな
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】